décryptage et analyse on va plus loin
[Musique]
on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés marie roger biloa des actrices
d'afrique international media group
bonjour marie roger est désormais avec
nous chaque mardi vous nous rejoignez et
c'est un plaisir bien sûr pour nous de
vous accueillir face à vous aujourd'hui
virginie herz chroniqueuse international
présentatrice a également dû magazine
actuel c'est sur france24 bonjour
virginie et place à la diplomatie tous
azimuts aujourd'hui volodymyr zelensky
s'est exprimé d'abord en visioconférence
aux communes à londres devant des
députés qui l'ont applaudi debout à
l'issue de son discours écoutez un
extrait bon tout l'état qui n'aviez pas
la donne on entend qu'il y aura de
l'aide aériennes qu'il y aura des avions
de combat pour nous soutenir mais tous
ces morts sous les bons dans les
dizaines de villes assiégées sont de la
responsabilité de la russie et des
militaires russes qui délibérément
exécutent ses ordres criminels et
détruisent le peuple ukrainien
toronto si
c'est aussi la responsabilité de tous
ceux à l'ouest depuis treize jours
n'arrive pas à prouver des décisions
pour protéger le ciel ukrainien d'autres
ces roquettes ces missiles pourtant il
pourrait le faire
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken lui était à l'elysée reçu par
emmanuel macron on ignore la teneur des
conversations nul doute qu'il s'agit
sans doute d'une préparation au sommet
de la fin de semaine aversa il ya le
président français qui doit accueillir
et bien ses homologues dans le but est
bien de parvenir à une position commune
face à l'ukraine jane stoltenberg le
secrétaire général de l'otan lui et et
en lettonie tout comme justin trudeau
premier ministre canadien ainsi que le
président du conseil espagnol président
du gouvernement espagnol pedro sanchez
un activisme diplomatique pour quoi
faire marie roger biloa négocier
simplement l'évacuation des civils est
donc livré d'une certaine manière
l'ukraine à la russie actes et donc la
prise du pays ou bien simplement gelé la
ligne de front ou encore préparer l'otan
les occidentaux à une possible
confrontation demain déjà ça je crois
que le camp occidental puisqu'il faut
l'appeler comme ça doit
vraiment explicite et ses buts
diplomatique comme on demande à vladimir
poutine de bien clarifier ses buts de
guerre puisqu'on en est on on sait pas
trop mais ce cet activisme diplomatique
comme vous dites intervient dans un
contexte particulier je crois que il
faut commencer par là parce que c'est la
seule chose qui reste sur la table
puisque d'emblée joe biden a dit qu'il
interrompt il n'interviendrait pas
novus underground comme il l'a dit et
que 2 sachant très bien qu'il y aurait
cette invasion militaire dont il a
prévenu tout le monde les alliés même
les chinois
si c'est pas une incitation ce n'est pas
un feu vert ça y ressemblait beaucoup
donc c'est sûr contexte cela qui fait
que devait même parler d'un temps
d'incursions joe biden ce qui avait lui
avait été beaucoup reproché laissant
entendre qu'une simple incursion selon
ses termes n'engendrerait pas de réponse
américaine exactement il a dit mais
c'était c'est une tendance générale qui
a commencé bien avant qu'obama commencé
près de la série mais qui a été émise en
oeuvre sans le moindre scrupule en
afghanistan ces dons c'est à ce moment
que poutine a saisi et il sait que ce
qui reste aux occidentaux actuellement
si seulement la parlotte si ils ne
peuvent pas agir sur le plan militaire
parce qu'ils ont déjà décidé de ne pas
faire mais aussi parce qu'il ya le
barrage
de la gare de la bombe atomique on peut
pas on les a vus freiné des quatre fers
à la porte de l'ukraine ce qui a fait
quand même 1 a provoqué quelques
commentaires caustiques en afrique on se
disait comment les européens ou les
français mais il est européen aussi
interviennent vont mourir pour bamako
mais peuvent pas aller mourir pour kiev
l'ukraine et donc on est dans une
situation extrêmement paradoxal et on
parle de diplomatie on voit le pauvre
volo 19 ans qui fait des vidéos tous les
jours et qui demande qui implorent les
européens d'agir on voit beaucoup de
compassion
partout mais on ne voit pas exactement
comment ils vont agir à part de temps en
temps à peut-être envoyer du matériel
militaire par la pologne par d'autres à
quoi peuvent servir ces réunions
effectivement virginie puisqu'on le voit
la crainte c'est d'aller vers un conflit
on ne veut pas non plus passer pour des
belligérants en même temps sinon ils
livrent des armes n'est ce pas justement
le risque oui mais c'est ça c'est à dire
que l'on refuse d'intervenir
militairement on refuse même la zone
d'exclusion aérienne ce qui aurait pu
quand même être voilà
une possibilité mais ça aussi ça a été
exclu d'imposer aux russes
mais le risque reste effectivement la
diplomatie néo sanctions économiques et
surtout de montrer un front uni et
finalement c'est aix et activisme
diplomatique c'est sa c2 se cordonner se
mettre à l'unisson est sur la même
longueur d'onde et tout à l'heure on l'a
entendu je byden insisté sur le fait que
dans l'embargo qu'il avait décidé à
propos du pétrole russes vers les états
unis il l'avait fait en accord avec des
alliés européens alors même que les
aéroports pour l'instant ne l'ont pas
pour montrer que la réponse sera commune
que le but sera commun qu'il n'ya un
front uni face à vladimir poutine même
s'il n'y a pas d'intervention militaire
l'illustration justement à ces sanctions
qui s'accumulent la dernière en date ont
mené l'audience virginie un embargo sur
le pétrole russes décrété par washington
écouter joe biden
nous interdisons toutes les importations
de pétrole de gaz et l'énergie russe
cela signifie que le pétrole russe ne
sera plus acceptée dans les ports
américains et que le peuple américain va
infliger un nouveau coup rude à la
machine de guerre de soucis
cette mesure a reçu un soutien
bipartisans au congrès mais aussi celui
de tout le pays nous avons pris cette
décision en coordination étroite avec
nos alliés et nos partenaires à travers
le monde particulièrement en europe car
une réponse unie à l'agression de
poutine a été ma priorité absolue que
l'otan lieux et nos alliés soient
totalement unie une anne marie roger on
ne peut pas risquer une confrontation
armée avec la russie un adversaire qu'on
considère aujourd'hui frappée du sceau
de l'irrationnel et qui pourrait donc
possiblement faire usage de l'armé
nucléaire il ne reste donc que l'arm
économique les sanctions et l'embargo
sur le pétrole est ce le moyen de faire
plier la russie et bien je crois que on
applique ces censures pour le principe
et on essaye de faire le plus mal
possible à l'économie russe mais chacun
vous dit qu'on n'aura pas de résultats
immédiats
est ce que on a vu des gens ce sens
c'est sans précédent on l'a assez dit
mais on ne voit pas la moindre inflexion
dans l'effort houle la volonté de
poutine de continuer sa guerre en
ukraine et c'est une situation vraiment
l étrange parce que sauf à rendre la
situation intenable pour les russes même
c'est ce que cherche à faire aujourd'hui
ça aussi ça aussi des implications pour
ceux qui appliquent les sanctions comme
on voit et l'histoire du pétrole était
le meilleur exemple puisque les
américains disent nous voilà ça y est
nous on arrête tout échanges pétroliers
avec la russie mais ils ont beau jeu de
faire ça parce qu'ils ne sont pas
dépendants du tout c'est pas le cas des
pays européens l'allemagne notamment
notamment et anna il ya des pays à 100%
comme dali certains pays baltes et sera
donc c'est très difficile et se sait
apparemment si on écoute les spéciales
et c'est la vraie mesure qui pourrait
faire la différence mais c'est très
difficile
illustration avec les propos du vice
président de la commission européenne
john stevens
tout est toujours sur la table je suis
sûr que nos chefs d'état de gouvernement
en reparlerons à versailles jeudi et
vendredi mais quand on impose des
sanctions il faut quand même savoir que
celui auquel on pose ses sanctions et
plus touchés par ces sanctions que celui
qui les imposent donc quand on fait ce
choix il faut être sûr qu'on frappe
surtout poutine est pas nous-mêmes
réalisme européen virginia qu'on ne va
pas pouvoir nous passer du gaz et du
pétrole russes c'est tout là c'est toute
la question à quel point est ce que les
européens mais même les citoyens
européens au delà des politiques sont
prêts à faire un acte de solidarité et a
par exemple dans les propositions qui
sont faites par la commission européenne
ça veut dire se chauffer moins par
exemple tout à l'heure dans le débat on
entendait un des intervenants de dire
voilà c'est aussi par exemple arrêter
d'avoir du chauffage dans les dents les
terrasses des terrasses des cafés faire
des efforts véritablement mais cela dit
euh oui internet pour que ceux qui n'ont
rien de comprennent bien moins de gaz
moins de pétrole ça veut dire davantage
de charbon ça veut dire accélérer les
renouvelables dès aujourd'hui donc et
changer nos habitudes absolument changer
les habitudes en tout cas c'est une des
pistes qui est proposée par la
commission européenne qui a suivi
l'agencé européenne de l'énergie donc il
ya accélération de la transition
énergétique utilisation à biomasse
ensuite diversification prendre du géant
fin du gaz liquéfié mais ça veut dire
que mettre en place des terminaux qui ne
sont pas encore suffisant donc ça ça va
prendre plusieurs années deux à trois
années donc à tout un tout une phase à
et changements d'habitudes et
acceptation aussi d'augmenter les prix
de l'énergie mais là aussi la commission
européenne pour le moment propose par
exemple de taxer les bénéfices des
compagnies pétrolières qui pour le
moment s'en sortent plutôt pas mal dans
cette crise pour justement compenser
pour ne pas avoir d des prix record de
l'essence notamment se montre la
complexité du problème mais oui c'est
une m'ont dit c'est un pansement un
cautère sur une jambe de bois parce que
on a ça fait très longtemps si on est
dans une situation n'a pas très envie de
d'énumérer toutes les erreurs qui ont
l'euro pe occidentales qui ont amené à
cette situation mais pour le parler que
de l'énergie ça fait des années sinon
des décennies qu'on parle de cette
autonomie énergétique peut-être pas les
libyens en tout cas beaucoup beaucoup de
temps et les américains
pour une fois ont toujours insisté sur
cette autonomie cette indépendance
énergétique ils ont fait des reprochant
aux européens alors demandé ça fait
aussi ça donne ça fait partie de leur
politique de demander aux hôpitaux
européens d'être autonome et de ne pas
être trop dépendant de la russie mais
puisque chacun a cru que la paix en fait
qu'est ce qui crée la paix entre et puis
nice et l'interdépendance et l'économie
et le commerce on s'est dit les russes
voilà ils font partie maintenant ils
sont dans la barque puisque on a des
échanges intenses avec eux ce genre de
situation pourrait ne plus arriver et
bien voilà je crois que c'est un rappel
très douloureux qu'il faut toujours
prévoir cela cela différemment le pari
que font tous cas les américains et
probablement des européens c'est que eux
ces mesures de sanction si sanction
économique touche quand même au final
plus le régime russe vladimir poutine et
ses proches plutôt que tout à l'heure le
président américain souligné que par
exemple le rouble était maintenant
valait à peine 1 pence et que voilà
qu'ils voulaient aussi saisir des biens
des oligarques russes qui soutiennent le
régime extra donc bien il vient quand
même sa pression chocolat lien en effet
hier il ya un pari d fait boule de neige
c'est aujourd'hui la journée
internationale des droits des femmes ça
ne vous a pas échappé à évidemment
virginie vous qui présentait magazine
actuel qui fait une large place
justement au rôle des femmes dans
l'actualité internationale
l'occasion pour nous donne un coup de
projecteur au rôle joué justement par
les femmes dans cette guerre en ukraine
écoutez olena by lozère ce cas elle est
un lieutenant dans l'armée ukrainienne
il me demandait toujours
être vous médecin ou tireuse d'élite
et maintenant l'armée s'est habitué à
laisser de la place aux femmes
artilleuses ingénieurs
je connais même deux ou trois femmes qui
commandent des tanks
[Musique]
l'armée a changé et la société a changé
je pense que l'armée ukrainienne et la
société ukrainienne
sont devenues plus fortes avec des
femmes fortes
est-ce l'héritage du soviétisme dans
lequel la femme avait quand même une
place très importante aussi à côté de
l'homme en tout cas on voit beaucoup de
femmes en avant dans ce conflit dans
cette guerre en ukraine marie roger
biloa oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
tout de même la guerre est l'un des
moments où le clivage homme/femme
ressort le plus parce que les enfants
inventent à la guerre qu'un beaucoup
plus que les femmes même si les les
femmes russes et ukrainiennes donc ont
leur place aussi au front un petit peu
mais surtout le elles sont elles sont
elles restent à un réseau où elle est
actuellement la contrainte à l'exil et
est livrée à toutes sortes de dangers
elle reste à la maison elles sont
surtout dans la résistance et a vu
beaucoup un ré salle maison ben c'est
une façon de parler parce qu'en réalité
elles sont et partent en exil et portait
un exil avec les enfants énormément mais
cela dit juste pour à propos de des
femmes dans l'armée ukrainienne au que
les femmes représentent à peu près 15 à
20 5% des effectifs de l'amérique
reaganienne et elles ont obtenu le droit
d'être dans des positions de combat
parce qu'à partir de 2014 et la guerre
du donbass et notamment cette uniquement
convoi health ont commencé à se battre
sans être autorisés et sa force de
pression que finalement elles ont obtenu
le droit de dire participer il ya un
effet boule de neige qui c'est un train
se faire alors quand vous si les femmes
ne représentent que 4% des effectifs
alors ça c'est les effectifs
dans l'armée c'est important et c'est
assez significatif mais ce qui me semble
plus significatif encore c'est que les
effets négatifs de la guerre sont
surtout portés par les femmes parce que
là comme on a vu ce conflit
spécifiquement elles sont en exil voir
les kits où elle avec les enfants et
elles sont aussi exposées à tous hommes
danger j'ai frappé ce matin d'entendre
représentant du hcr parler par exemple
de prédateur sexuel le viol comme arme
de guerre et senna qui attendent à la
frontière mais le côté positif quand
même bon puisqu'on a vu le canada
réussit et qui très en pointe dans ce
conflit en faveur de la lutte contre ce
qu'on fait il ya trois femmes qu'ils
soient en première ligne il faut relever
leur rôle c'est la vice premier ministre
et en même temps ministre des finances
mélanie joly qui minent un fake ministre
des affaires étrangers et surtout anita
anam de chemistry du fond c'est qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure aux côtés de justes et
côtés de justin trudeau en vous et et en
lettonie et qui a pris la parole ce
chemin pour avec beaucoup de force et
détermination merci beaucoup marie roger
biloa bas ce sera le mot de la fin pour
honorer justement ces figures aussi de
l'actualité internationale merci
virginie at on va revenir justement en
images sur les événements de cette
journée en ukraine et on se retrouve
dans six minutes maintenant pour un
nouveau journal
[Musique]